[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
consacrée à la crise du crédit yens
alors que joe biden a évoqué une guerre
imminente et que les ressortissants de
la quasi totalité des pays occidentaux
quittent le pays le président ukrainien
volodimir hélas qui a invité d'ailleurs
joe biden à se rendre sur place dans les
prochains jours les russes ont exercé
des manoeuvres en mer noire ce week-end
et olaf scholz vous voyez est à kiev il
se rendra d'ailleurs à moscou demain le
chancelier allemand tente donc une
ultime carte diplomatique
comment les ukrainiens se prépare-t-il
comment analyser la réponse de joe biden
olaf scholz fait-il de la diplomatie
doit être dernière chance comment éviter
l'engrenage d'une guerre on en débat
avec mes invités j'ai plaisir d'avoir à
mes côtés jean de gliniasty bonsoir
ancien ambassadeur de france à moscou
directeur de recherche de l'institut de
relations internationales et
stratégiques hauteur de petite histoire
des relations franco russes et séchez
l'inventaire bienvenue à vous j'ai fait
hawkins bonsoir ancien ambassadeur
américain cette fois et professeur à
sciences po cherchant également à l'iris
nous avons avec non duplex de berlin
armand zorn député du spd bonsoir à vous
et bienvenus
bonsoir également avec nous parce
qu'avec de kiev en ukraine tetyana
hoggar kova journaliste responsable du
département international à l'ukraine
crisis media center bonsoir et bienvenue
à vous également
la quasi totalité des ressortissants
occidentaux en ukraine kit l'ukraine on
va écouter quelques uns d'entre eux
avant de démarrer ce débat
[Musique]
2010 nous approchons
grosse panique
nous sommes dans la norme dans nombre
d'îles
vous allez voir que de nombreux
ukrainiens s'entraîne le à faire la
guerre
dans le centre de kiev la pizzeria des
vétérans une adresse que connaissent
tous les militaires d'ukrainiens
sur les murs les médailles obtenues sur
le champ de bataille par le patron
leonid hostas tête et ses camarades
aujourd'hui il encourage ses concitoyens
à prendre les armes et pour ceux qui en
achètent une c'est une pizza offerte
patriote il va aussi dans les tranchées
ont fait des pizzas sur la ligne de
front et on les livre directement dans
les tranchées
et quelquefois c'est sous le feu une
pizza chaude coca frais c'est juste le
bonheur
les ukrainiens met un point d'honneur à
continuer une vie normale malgré les
cent trente mille russe massées aux
portes du pays
mais la guerre tous y pensent
c'est très dur de savoir ce qu'il va se
passer dans les prochains jours on ne
sait même pas s'il y aura un demain
tout peut disparaître du jour au
lendemain
leonid ne se contente pas de faire
tourner sa pizzeria ancien tireur
d'élite il forme les plus jeunes cette
partie là doit toujours être au centre
son équipement son arme il les garde en
permanence avec lui il a combattu plus
d'un an dans le donbass contre les
miliciens pro russe son obsession
aujourd'hui que les civils puissent
défendre leur patrie en cas d'invasion
russe
ça des tarés près de chez nous qui
veulent envahir notre pays donc il faut
qu'on soit prêt
mais on espère que la diplomatie
fonctionne car si on est une personne
sensée on ne veut pas la guerre
tetiana hoggar kova vous êtes donc à
kiev quelles sont les réactions sur
place face aux évacuations et à
l'annulation des vols en direct de
l'ukraine les ukrainiens reste-t-il
calme est ce qu'ils se sentent isolés
est ce qu ils ont peur
bonsoir alors effectivement après les
actualités que nous avons reçues que la
plupart des saint martial d'évacuer leur
personnel les membres de famille y
compris aussi les instructeurs
militaires et après on a aussi reçu la
nouvelle sur l'évacuation sur le départ
si vous voulez de membres de la mission
de monitoring de haut et c'est bien sûr
ça crée une espèce de transfert
anxiogène à kiev est partout dans le
pays parce que les ukrainiens se sentent
est effectivement un peu délaissé par
les étrangers mais à la fois je dirais
que la majorité d'ukrainiens comprennent
que c'est une suite logique des
déclarations qui ont été faites
récemment pendant les dernières semaines
sur la menace qui était imminente alors
si les menaces est imminente alors il
est clair que les ambassades les pays
étrangers doivent prendre des
précautions pour protéger leurs citoyens
ce qui est tout à fait compréhensible
donc je dirais que la situation est
divisée d'un côté un côté émotion bien
sûr que dans l'état d'un des leurs dans
les moments un peu dur on se sent un peu
seuls les vrais donc on va pas le cacher
à la fois on voit la logique déception
jean de gliniasty est ce que ces
évacuations sont synonymes justement
d'une préparation à une guerre
je ne sais pas c'est très difficile de
les interpréter moi j'y vois aussi une
pression indirecte sur l'ukraine aussi
parce que qui souffre en fait de ces
préparatifs de guerre c'est les
ukrainiens et on voyait très bien que
zelensky disait ou le laquelle mais vous
c'est pas si grave que ça et il ya une
espèce de contradiction dans la position
ukrainienne c'est à dire que ils veulent
se préparer à une guerre éventuelle mais
en même temps il voudrait pas que cette
préparation aboutissent à paralyser une
économie chrétienne qui commençait à se
relever puisque zelensky ya quinze jours
se félicitait que pour la première fois
depuis 30 ans le pib ukrainien commencé
à croître donc c'est un désastre
économique pour les ukrainiens ce qui se
passe et donc c'est abouti en fait à
faire pression sur le site craignent en
fait tu y vois aucun des états unis
justement il ya beaucoup de
contradictions aussi au sein à
washington puisque il ya eu ce débat
d'ailleurs ce week-end sur la
dramatisation de joe byden certains aux
etats-unis sont sceptiques ils font même
un parallèle avec les armes de
destruction massive supposé en irak est
ce que c'est un coup de bluff de byden
on peut pas aller jusque là non je pense
que cobain ne cherche à
montrer une fierté vis-à-vis des russes
on n'a pas du tout négliger la
diplomatie mais en même temps se prépare
et on essaie de rassembler autour de
nous nos alliés et notamment le temps et
en ce qui concerne les préparatifs des
évacuations et autres pour moi c'est
quelque chose de tout à fait normal si
on est dans une période de stress
détention ce serait irresponsable de ne
pas évacuer les ressortissants
américains ne pas réduire les effectifs
à l'ambassade
dans le cas où éventuellement il y aura
des hostilités mais il ya des des voix
dissonantes à washington
ça c'est une question de polarisation
politique américaine qui n'a rien à voir
avec l'ukraine mais je pense en général
ce qui est plutôt étonnant c'est que les
une partie du parti républicain est plus
ou moins sur la même longueur d'onde du
président il y à des extrêmes droites 30
pistes qui parle de rentrer bayrou c'est
ses relations éventuelles avec avec les
ukrainiens mais sinon le parti démocrate
et une bonne partie du parti républicain
sont solidaires derrière les ukrainiens
et avec nos alliés de l'otan alors aulas
chaude sans le sang le chancelier
allemand je le disais en titre et à kiev
on va l'écouter
les activités militaires de la russie à
la frontière ukrainienne ne sont pas
compréhensibles c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
motifs raisonnables pour un tel
déploiement militaire
nous attendons que la russie prenne des
mesures claires de désescalade
pour l'allemagne tous agression
militaire envers l'ukraine aurait de
sérieuses conséquences politiques et
économiques et géostratégiques pour la
rue
armand aux ordres vous êtes député du
spd berlin a évacué son personnel
également de l'ambassade de kiev il a
rappelé ses ressortissants qui travaille
également dans les organisations
internationales en ukraine should
demande à la russie de saisir les offres
de dialogue quelles peuvent être les
résultats on sait qu'il va demain en
russie quelles peuvent être les
résultats du chancelier
premièrement je tiens a constaté que le
fait que le chancelier est aujourd'hui à
kiev et se rend demain moscou c'est
quand même un signe qui meurent à un peu
optimiste parce que ça prouve qu'il ya
quand même un diallo qui est encore en
place dans ce qui fait que
vraiment la guerre on n'est pas encore
arrivé on n'est pas arrivé à ce niveau
de guerre donc je pense que la visite
aux lâches liste noire moscou sera ce
très très stratégique il a été très
clair aujourd'hui d'ailleurs aussi le
président stein mayer a été très clair
hier que l'allemagne que le gouvernement
est aussi le peuple allemand se sent
solidaire avec le peuple ukrainien et
que nous avons de très nets attentes ce
qui concerne poutine le président
poutine quand je pense que demain on
attend un peu aussi de la russie de
montrer un peu quelques signes d des
installations est d'ailleurs j'apprécie
ce que le sag et le ministre des
affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov a dit
aujourd'hui il a aussi insisté qu' il
reste encore une voie des négociations
une voie diplomatique et j'espère que
c'est ce que le président putschiste va
dire de nos filles jean de gliniasty
vous pensez que la chose peut réussir
insuffler une désescalade
écoutez je chacun contribue en allant à
moscou mc on a cru qu'il n'est pas
vraiment un succès pour l'instant c'est
pas un succès pour la désescalade mais
il ya des choses qui se passent quand
même faut bien voir qu'il ya un élément
nouveau par rapport aux crises
précédentes ya peut-être plus de troupes
russes en effet mais surtout il ya une
négociation sur des textes qui a été
lancée avec une proposition russe
qualifié au départ de à prendre ou à
laisser et puis une réponse américaine
très et alliés des traits technique même
du département d'état très sérieuse
alors les russes ont dit bien sûr ça
répond pas tout ce qu'on en demande il
ya une négociation qui est engagée
samedi je ne veux pas parler à la place
de mon ami américain mais samedi il ya
eu un entretien des ministres la défense
des ministres des affaires étrangères de
byden poutine ya une négociation en
cours c'est ça les mêmes l'élément
principal et ensuite la gesticulation
c'est l'accompagnement normal d'une
bonne négociation normale à condition du
snuep alpha bâ alias oeil de
gesticulations tous les éléments sont
réunis pour une offensive forte la
russie ça c'est jean yves le drian une
déclaration donc camp auquel
voilà qui nous parvient à l'instant on
va écouter d'ailleurs joe biden au micro
de sonia dridi pas redondant tony
blinken le chef de la diplomatie
américaine au micro de notre
correspondante à washington sonia dridi
une agression dès cette semaine est tout
à fait possible quand on voit ce qui se
passe autour de l'ukraine avec le
déploiement des forces russes est ce que
le président bailly donne pourrait se
rendre en ukraine comme le demande le
président ukrainien c'est pour l'instant
le président est très engagé dans la
diplomatie il a parlé aujourd'hui avec
le président annonce qu'il avait parlé
auparavant avec le président poutine on
retient toute hypothèse pour avancer le
diplôme aussi mais dans un premier temps
ça dépend entièrement de la russie
est-ce qu'ils vont poursuivre un retrait
des forces qui entourent le crème pour
donner l'opportunité à la diplomatie
d'essayer de résoudre les problèmes qui
existent ou au contraire est-ce qu'ils
vont continuer a
annoncé lé mans maintenir mais accroître
leurs forces qui sont déployés autour de
lichens et puis agir avec une agression
aussi sauf que cette semaine il faut que
les gens comprennent les outils que les
russes dans le passé et aujourd'hui
mettre à leur service y compris la
création de fausse provocation pour
justifier une intervention qui était
bien planifiée auparavant c'est tout à
fait dans l'or dans leur logique et
justement mettre la lumière là dessus
c'est peut-être un moyen de l'éviter
interview exclusive dans la langue de
molière à vous l'avez vu dans tony
blinken fars si on sonia dridi on voit
bien en tout cas que voilà la menace et
il vous remy nantes 1 pour les
américains jeffrey rock'n ce même si la
diplomatie mais il a l'air de dire tout
même anthony blinken que la balle est
dans le camp des russes mais que rien
n'est joué pour l'instant on va voir
mais justement c'est poutine qui doit
décider de la guerre ou de la paix
ce qui est certain c'est que les
américains avec leurs amis et vont faire
face ensemble tetiana regarde regarde
kovac est ce que vous pensez justement
de cette médiation de du chancelier
choles
écouter en effet change les choses a
fait sa visite aujourd'hui acquis hier
on a bien entendu sa conférence de
presse ensemble avec soin avec président
zielinski
évidemment également est un pays clé
pour l'ukraine puisqu'il ya le format
normandie où il ya la france également
la france allemagne qui sont médiateur
dans le conflit dans la guerre si vous
voulez qui existe entre l'ukraine et la
russie depuis huit ans où les rues si
l'agresseur bien sûr c'était une visite
atteint duke ont été atteintes d'où la
visite de président en macro la semaine
dernière il y aquelques quelque chose à
gérer quelques grands thèmes à discuter
notamment les sanctions contre la russie
en cas d' attaque puisque la tacc que
arriver à n'importe quel moment malgré
les efforts diplomatiques
deuxième volet des négociations c'est no
stream 2 qui reste pour l'ukraine je
tiens à rappeler quand même une arme
âgées géopolitique de la russie clé
qu'elle essaie d'utiliser pour contrôler
pour pour faire force si vous voulez en
europe donc et nous prennent avait
commencé et ce sujet à prévenir que nord
stream de ce n'est pas un projet
économique mais c'est bien un projet
géopolitique donc on avait commencé à en
parler bien longtemps et bien sûr il ya
un sujet encore plus pénible sur le
supplément des armes on sait on qu'on
est bien on respecte bien sûr la
position de l'allemagne là dessus mais
dans la question de la solidarité
européenne sur la nécessité de d'aider
l'ukraine dans l'état de guerre donc le
bien sûr la position de l'allemagne et
une différente d'eau étaient nécessaires
dans 2
de parler de ce sujet là à voir que
olafsen se rendent à moscou et on voit à
suivre la situation très attentivement
armand zorn justement l'allemagne sera t
elle prête à arrêter nord stream 2 en
cas d'incursion russe en ukraine
je tiens quand même à revenir un peu sur
le commentaire que ma collègue donne pas
ses yeux c'est vraiment c'est que dans
ce monde qui est à ce point là qui est
important par de la kryte qu'on parle de
la crise ukrainienne en ce moment c'est
aussi bien sûr une crise économique qui
ne tient qu'à un média que le chant
seller olaf scholz a quitté voilà qui
est écrit aujourd'hui et il a laissé un
crédit de 150 millions un million
d'euros c'est quelque chose qui va un
peu supporter aussi la situation
économique en ukraine maintenant ce qui
concerne maintenant nordstream deux là
je trouve que quand vous voyez bien ce
que l'achat le sadi et qui est
aujourd'hui depuis un certain moment
c'est qu'en fait en cas d'invasion russe
toutes les options sont sur la table ont
fait dans ce cas on parle des
conséquences politiques ont paradé
conséquences économiques des grands pas
aussi des conséquences géostratégiques
et je pense que ça s'est quand même
clair et ça nous montre un peu ce qui
est possible quant à clairement
pardonnez moi ils me sifflent a
clairement nos stream 2 le chancelier
allemand me semble-t-il il ne le fait
pas je suis d'accord avec vous je suis
d'accord avec vous il ne le fait pas
mais je tiens car insisté quand se
trouve dans les négocions vers les
négociations diplomatiques
personnellement je pense que la
meilleure manière d'atteindre un
résultat satisfaisant un résultat pour
tout le monde n'est pas d'avancé de
menace était menacée et menaces mais
plutôt de montrer la voie diplomatique
qui se pose et je trouve qu'en disant
qu'une invasion aura aussi des
conséquences économiques si vous me
demandez je pense que c'est très clair
ce qui est ce qu'on veut dire par là
face en tout cas aux cent trente mille
soldats russes l'otan renforce son
dispositif en roumanie par exemple il ya
déploiement des renforts militaires
américains dans le sud est du pays à une
quinzaine de kilomètres de la mer noire
la roumanie dont je vous le rappelle est
dans l'otan et on y retrouve à bucarest
notre correspondant mirel bran mirel
bonsoir des blindés stryker et 1000
militaires d'ailleurs ont été déployés
au bord de la mer noire on peut dire que
les roumains se prépare à une guerre
contre les russes
on ne serait pas là quelque chose
qui est plutôt méchant ici on a un
rapport
assez on a toute une histoire derrière
avec dans le rapport avec la russie on a
la peur de la russie dans notre adn
on a eu la période communiste
on a eu le communiste parce que l'armée
rouge est intervenu et que le communisme
était garde un peu partout à l'ouest à
l'est de l'europe grâce à la à la mer
rouge il ya encore des vieux dans ce
village que vous avez évoquées à
melbourne où il ya les mille soldats
américains qui ont débarqué qui se
rappellent qu'ils se rappellent cette
période là et ils n'ont dit j'étais sûr
passé m'ont dit que si les américains
n'étaient pas là ce serait l'élu ce qui
serait là donc on a fait peur c'est par
un certain ancestral de la russie
maintenant terre de l'ombre évidemment
on peut pas comparer les cent mille
soldats que le président russe vladimir
poutine a déployé à proximité de la
frontière ukrainienne avec les quelques
milliers de soldats américains et sur le
banc de l'otan parce qu'il n'ya pas que
des américaines à la majorité d'entre
eux sont américains qui se trouvaient à
vous maniez la roumanie compte six bases
de l'otan qui sont la plupart d'entre
elles sont contrôlées par l'armée
américaine et sur les six bases on a
aussi un bouclier antimissile et ce
bouclier antimissile qui énerve beaucoup
vladimir poutine parce que la russie
accuse la roumanie l otan
de la possibilité de mettre des
missiles offensive contre la russie avec
avec ce bouclier antimissile en fait
c'est un bouclier les américains les
autorités roumaines ont toujours dit que
c'est un bouclier pour des buts
défensive mais les russes continuent à
croire et être persuadé qu'on va les
attaquer depuis la roumanie bon ça c'est
le discours un peu guerrier qu'on entend
en ce moment mais les faits c'est qu'en
roumanie on a quelques milliers de
soldats américains
ils sont pas aussi nombreux que les
russes mais c'est pas leur nombre qui
compte c'est
la symbolique de cette présence à partir
du moment où on touche à la roumanie où
on touche on touche là à l'otan et aux
touches surtout aux états unis qui sont
un partenaire stratégique dans la
roumanie dans cette équation merci à
gefco qui se diraient mes seins qu'elle
choisisse la roumanie plutôt que la
turquie
jours
évidemment ils ont retiré 150 soldats
d'ukraine j'ai vu et des notamment des
soldats formateur les etats-unis ne vont
pas envoyer de soldats en ukraine s'il
ya danger et il faut qu'on soit en a 400
ici ni les états unis ni l'otan comptent
partir en guerre contre la russie
si éventuellement les russes décident
d'envahir l'ukraine on va pas il y aura
pas de repenser militaire mais il y aura
des sanctions il y aura des actions rp
quoi saison voire même des soldats en
roumanie pour souligner à poutine que le
ton reste
solidaire et si jamais davanture il
pense à aller plus loin que l'ukraine on
est là on est prêt ça nous est dissuasif
oui absolument mais en attendant on a
tout à une suite de sanctions qui est
déjà préparée déjà discuter d'avancés
justement à cuers et préparé les
américains à une guerre hybride
cyberattaques guerre économique
un peu de tout et le nous on présume que
si jamais il ya des sanctions contre lui
a réussi là la russie va répliquer et
certainement avec des moyens asymétrique
et notamment dans le domaine du cyber et
on est prêt pour cette éventualité
mais on ne peut pas non plus laisser des
ukrainiens à 100 sans soutien de la
communauté internationale donc on est on
est on est prêt à faire face à ces
menaces eurus s'il le faut mais on ne va
pas aller en guerre jean de gliniasty
cette guerre ce sera donc pas si elle
effectivement guerre il y a il n'y aura
pas une riposte militaire de la part du
camp occidental ce sera d'abord des
sanctions économiques ça sera en ukraine
non mais s'ils l'attaquent l'otan bien
sûr qu'il réunira le poste collectif ça
fait partie de la déclassant à cannes
mais encore une fois il ya deux canaux
de négociations qui sont en cours qui
sont très importants sur la sécurité de
l'ensemble du continent un autre pour la
crise ukrainienne qui est le format
normandie ces deux canaux fonctionne
plus ou moins bien et c'est ça
l'essentiel c'est ça l'essentiel la bce
pourtant appelle les banques à jean de
gliniasty à mieux se prémunir contre les
risques de cyber attaques russes est ce
que les occidentaux se préparent à cette
guerre asymétrique guerre une
cyberattaque cyberguerre j'imagine oui
ça fait partie de tout le monde tout le
monde veut le faire les russes sont pas
mauvais là dedans les occidentaux ne
sont pas mauvais non plus
son excellent
je voulais aussi souligner un aspect de
justement de cette question là et ça
s'est plusieurs fois des prix et que la
crise a éclaté on a fait des annonces
déjà l intention éventuelle des russes
c'est à dire l'envoi de dessin doutes ou
des gens qui allaient monter
des coups et c'est
certainement évidemment basés sur les
renseignements américains et ça de même
moi j'ai pas de d'autres exemples ce
genre de deux annonces preventative
basés sur les
renseignements c'est assez intéressant
et donc et donc c'est pour justement
pour dire à poutine en suit de très près
ce que vous faites on va annoncer ça
publiquement parce que comme ça une fois
que vous le faites ça a beaucoup moins
d'impact si on a annoncé d'avancé mais
c'est très rare
2 enfin mettre en danger no no no no no
réseau de renseignement justement pour
parier à
ce que les meilleures technologies dans
le même temps il ya des négociations qui
se passe pas si mal que ça entre les
américains et les russes sur un code de
bonne conduite cybernétique qui est
issue directement de l'entretien byden
poutine de juin dernier et apparemment
ça marche pas si mal donc encore une
fois il ya un processus de négociations
en cours sur ce on a été attaqué
plusieurs fois par les russes et
notamment pendant nos élections en 2016
en 2018-2020 donc on est un peu
c'est presque
7ème art aux gars qu'on va vous aussi
d'ailleurs les ukrainiens ont fait
l'objet d' attaque de cyber attaques de
la part des russes ça ferait partie de
cette guerre
bah justement vous avez tout à fait
raison de dire que ce pas une guerre
classique on est à 1 21e siècle il
s'agit bien d'une guerre hybride et donc
à partir de 2014 après l'annexion
illégale de la crimée et l'occupation
illégale de dopage jusqu'à rappeler il y
avait énormément de tentative de
déstabiliser la situation en ukraine par
des moyens que ce soit que ce que
c'était des cyberattaques que ça c'était
des moyens en semi politique de
déstabilisation alors que et où ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui de théâtres en fête de
guerre qu'on voit aujourd'hui cet
échange de menaces et puis de prévention
comme sa part par les paroles ça devient
en quelque sorte est réel et virtuel à
quelque 100 sauvegarder nos en aucun nom
n'est en état de détention extrêmes je
dirais depuis trois mois au minimum et
pourtant rien ne se ne se passe en fait
rien se passe ni à paris ni à berlin on
y accueille m ni à moscou mais admettez
bien que tout le monde et ils sont un dû
et on se croit vraiment en passe une
membre de la troisième où je sais pas
quatrième guerre mondiale quatrième si
on si on compte 1 la guerre froide comme
le troisième guerre mondiale ou bien la
troisième guerre vraie guerre c'est à
dire que on est
vraiment dans la réalité mais pas
seulement dans les réalités physiques
mais de la réalité virtuelle en quelque
sorte où ce jeu psychologique
joue beaucoup et je voudrais dire que
les russes ont en quelque sorte au
maître dans ce jeu aujourd'hui parce que
ils jouent ils vendent à quelque sorte
cette peur et voilà c'est un peu la
vente de chantage
il arrive en quelque sorte leurs jokers
qu'ils arrivent à à faire jean avoir
peur en quelque sorte alors montez en
êtes d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
christiana aux gars comme il ya une
forme de guerre psychologique dans cet
affrontement avec la russie vous
ressentez ça en allemagne
je suis tout à fait d'accord justement
je trouve que quand on se trouve dans
une situation pareille avec une guerre
psychologique avec une guerre
asymétrique
je pense qu'il est plus important de
réfléchir au deuxième ou troisième pas
avant de penser aux premiers pas et je
trouve que justement ce qu'on a vu ces
derniers jours avec d'ailleurs la
collaboration très étroite entre la
france et l'allemagne est aussi avec les
états unis je trouve que ça c'est un bon
chemin qu'ont appris et je tiens à le
souligner le plus important c'est de
toujours rester dans le dialogue mais
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure la balle
est dans le camp de la russie dans le
camp du président poutine le chancelier
olaf scholz a formulé ses attentes dont
nous attendons que dès demain il ya des
signes du d'escalation est à base de sa
selle on peut continuer le dialogue on
peut continuer avec le dialogue donc la
désescalade vous pensez que c'est pour
demain au moment où la flotte sierra
voir vladimir poutine il faut que la
désescalade soit pas soit pour demain ou
en tout cas aura peut-être pas de
nouvelles escalades mais quand on dit
que la balle est dans le camp de poutine
c'est à la fois vrai et faux pour la
décalade sans aucun doute pour le format
normandie c'est un petit peu différent
parce que nous savons très bien puisque
ça a été dit par le ministre des
affaires étrangères ukrainien et ça a
été dit puis rattraper si je puis dire
par le président hélène ski que les
ukrainiens ne veulent pas d accor domine
ce quoi en tout cas ont une
interprétation des accords de minsk qui
ne sont qui ne sont pas exactement faim
n'est pas une verrue celle des russes
mais qui est à vrai dire il faut le dire
contraire aux textes quand on lit je
suis désolé de le dire notre miel mais
quand on lit le texte c'est clair que la
récupération des frontières par les
troupes ukrainienne c'est la dernière
étape d'un processus
et l'enjeu c'est le vote du statut
spécial d'abord par les dombes à pau le
dombass ce que les russes demandent est
ce que les ukrainiens refusent donc en
fait lorsque la filière j'allais dire
franco-allemande de contribution à la
paix est en route
la question qui se pose c'est est ce
qu'on va pouvoir surmonter cette
difficulté fondamentale sur
l'application des accords domine ce qui
est là l'ukraine a une petite part à
jouer je crois tetiana au regard kowalik
rana une petite part à jouer sur les
accords de minsk pied du mur là jean de
gliniasty
oui c'est le sujet est vaste je sais pas
si je serai tout expliquer un deux trois
minutes je vois que les collections tout
à fait au courant de la complexité du
sujet mais si on parle de désaccord de
minsk il faut tout d'abord prendre en
compte le moment où les accords le
protocole a été signé on aimerait bien
en 2015 et donc il ya le livre
passionnant de françois hollande
président de la france ex-président de
la france qui est qui a raconté la nuit
en fait d'eux des signatures s'était
c'était au moment très dur où les
troupes russes avançait dans le
territoire ukrainien et c'était les
accords signés sous menace tout à fait
réelle
défensive de la russie dont ils ont été
forcés de signer des ukrainiens en force
et c'est une chose deuxième chose si on
lit les accords du mif qui a les numéros
pour chaque fois si vous lisez voilà si
on lit et trois premiers points nos
bleus cessez-le-feu le retrait de
troupes et puis l'échangé de prisonniers
au camp point notre n'en étaient jamais
fait accompli par la russie dit
publiquement qu'il n'y avait pas le
cessez le feu donc si on commence à
réaliser à accomplir les accords de
ministre au temps de commencer par le
début autant de commencer par le volet
sécuritaire dont sécurité d'abord
règlement politique ensuite ceux ci
était une nation sphère politique de
l'ukraine et les rencontres à bernand la
semaine dernière après confirmé une fois
de plus que ici la position de l'ukraine
est très ferme mais pour nous ce qui est
important c'est la sécurité d'abord il
ya des occupations
elle ces territoires ddt et l'armée
russe voilà et ensuite le règlement
politique délégation et tout est
possible jean de gliniasty or ce ne sont
pas ce que veulent les russes les russes
glace des interprétations différentes
les russes s'en tiennent au texte même
des accords de minsk et considère que la
priorité c'est le statut spécial les
sucres et en restant donc sur place les
séparatistes au russe donc ils partiront
enfin les rebelles les forces armées
tout ça seront désarmés en dernière
étape et les ukrainiens veulent d'abord
le désarmement le respect des clauses
militaire avant d'entamer le statut et
donc ne sont pas d'accord ils vont
réussir ce métro d'appel c'est à dire
que les décisions ne trouvent pas un
compromis
le deuxième axe de négociations et dieu
sait si le problème ukrainien est
crucial il est paralysé donc il faut
trouver un accord il ya une formule
allemande on a appelé la formule stein
mayer que les ukrainiens n'accepte que
du bout des lèvres ils sont pas
tellement d'accord mais il y à des
formules de compromis il faut qu'on les
trouve jusque là dans le cas du format
normandie on a plutôt essayé d'assouplir
la position russe il va falloir qu'on
trouve un accord tetiana regard qu'on va
écouter des prestations du côté
ukrainien
écoutez on peut parler des concessions
on peut parler des blocs du plô massy
mais il faut regarder les choses en face
c'est puissant se cacher d'un d'aller à
ne pas essayer de se couper un cheval 4
ce que vous la russie la russie veut que
l'ukraine accepte une région qu'elle
n'est pas contrôlée par l'ukraine une
région qui m'irrite arisée où il ya des
arbres ou russe où il ya sous contrôle
russe en fait c'est ça que vous la
russie ce que veulent ukraine l'ukraine
veut récupérer les régions qui lui
appartient mais les régions démilitarisé
sans armes sans troupes
pro russe russe sans sans armes en fait
et puis qu il contrôle bien la frontière
et ensuite après une période de
transition puisque après la guerre après
le traumatisme que cette région a vécu
il faut quand même une période de
transition il faut passer à au processus
politique
reconstruction il a de la réconciliation
avec le club ceci est tout à fait
naturel ceci est tout à fait faisable
tout ce que je crains c'est que la
russie parts et quelques ailerons ces
contrôles qu'elle exerce sur ses
territoires voilà c'est vraiment le
point d'achoppement d'ailleurs sur sur
ces accords un mot armand horn puisque
le chancelier allemand va donc en russie
à moscou demain est ce que il va revenir
sur justement ces accords de minsk
est-ce qu'il va obtenir quelque chose de
vladimir poutine vous avez un espoir
pour répondre aux questions de façon
honnêtement je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas s'il va aborder l'accord des
ministres main mais j'ai espoir que il
va rentrer avec une situation un peu
plus favorable un peu meilleur que la
situation en ce moment il pourrait
réussir là où finalement le président
français a échoué
non je ne dirais pas ainsi ben je pense
pas que le président français ait échoué
comme je disais tout à l'heure je trouve
que l'allemagne la france les états unis
ont très bien collaboré sur ce sujet et
je pense que on ne peut pas voir cette
visite du président des chantiers
allemande en ce moment comme un comme un
mouvement qu'il a fait de lui même je
pense qu'il ya eu un accord très un
accord une collaboration très étroite
avec la france avec le président
français donc au final si la russie
demain ce sera une réussite pour
l'occident une réussite pour la
diplomatie jean guéguéniat si vous y
êtes diplomate ça va fonctionner ou pas
cette entrevue entre olaf scholz et
melvin c'est une pierre c'est une pierre
à l'édifice et encore une fois la france
et l'allemagne ont une responsabilité
particulière dans cette crise en plus la
france occupe la présidence du conseil
des ministres de l'union européenne et
donc je pense d'ailleurs que ce serait
l'intérêt des russes aussi de de donner
à cette piste format normandie un peu
plus de substance et ça serait l'intérêt
aussi des ukrainiens donc cette piste
est ouverte malheureusement le le groupe
tripartite qui s'est réuni à deux cas
réparti depardon s'est réunie
magne et ça n'a pas marché aussi il n'y
a pas d'accord il n'y a pas d'accord
donc c'est parce que les ukrainiens
d'ailleurs zelensky a été accueilli un
peu un héros comme premier groupe parce
qu'ils ont tenu bon si je puis dire et
le prochain groupe est en mars mais
quand il faut espérer que cette filière
finissent par donner des résultats parce
qu'elle conditionne le succès de
l'entreprise générale d'établissement
d'une nouvelle architecture de sécurité
en europe en attendant à joe biden est
toujours plutôt dramatique toujours la
situation on va l'écouter président
américain
on me dit qu'on l'a pas bon en fait
dramatise la situation vous le savez est
ce qu'il peut attendre lui est ce que
les américains attendent quelque chose
de cette visite de olaf scholz à moscou
je pense que tout ou doit on doit
revenir et
analyser un peu ce qui pourrait être les
intentions de poutine et je pense au
moins du côté américain les questions
sur le danba c'est tout ça c'est
important est évidemment c'est un
différend entre l'ukraine et la russie
mais médias poutine est juste sur
d'autres résistent rossi il ya une
ukraine qui est démocratique à ses
frontières et donc les révolue
révolution de couleur et c'est ça qui
pose problème pour un régime très
autoritaire il y à une éventuelle
participation de l'ukraine dans l'otan
ça c'est pas pour demain mais enfin il y
à aussi
ce désir ce besoin de deux d'affirmer le
sphère d'influencé de la russie sur ce
qui était l'ancien urss une affiche de
lanières poutine et tout ça et donc des
négociations sur telle ou telle question
de technique c'est importante c'est très
important mais
si tout cela n'est pas
soutenu par par
alliance unis et est prêt à aller
jusqu'aux sanctions et peut-être au-delà
si on est attaqué ça marcherait pas
parce que poutine
et c'est pas juste il ne vise que pas
que l'ukraine voilà c'est l'europe est
unie alors oui à l'europe
non l'europe n'est pas unie enfin l'été
les unit maintenant une plus ample unis
mais l'europe n'est pas partie prenante
elle même s'est mise hors jeu puisqu'ils
ont refusé une initiative particulière
vis-à-vis de poutine camp merkel et et
mâcon l'ont proposé après le sommet
baden mais les rentrer dans ce jeu à
nouveau l'europe non avec ligne par le
biais de l'allemagne et de la france oui
c'est par ce biais là mais je voudrais
dire une chose
l'analyse que de 2,2 fait de poutine par
mon collègue américain et est exact mais
il ya un point quand même qui me paraît
important c'est que il semble
qu'actuellement
compte tenu de la naissance d'un vrai
sentiment national en ukraine qui n'a
pas pu ne pas échapper enfin qui a même
pas pu échapper pardon à poutine je
crois que poutine est prêt à échanger en
quelque sorte de la sécurité contre bas
de la liberté pour l'ukraine est de donc
de renoncer en partie à sa zone
d'influencé
si on lui donne la sécurité et cela il
faudrait quoi une sorte de il faudra
remettre à plat l'ensemble de la
sécurité on essaie ce qui se passe
actuellement c'est ce qui se passe le
projet de réponse à mai le projet de
traité russe c'est ça à la russe si je
puis dire il ya un projet américain une
réponse américaine extrêmement précises
très technique vraiment très bien fait
qui est une réponse je la demande de
moscou de revenir entière de 1997 si je
puis dire mais ça c'est un refus bien
sûr mais il ya des d'autres éléments
très positifs et donc il ya eu
négociation importante qui s'engage sur
la sécurité en europe et ça ça concerne
tous les européens premier chef et c'est
vraiment l'essentiel et l'ukraine en
bénéficiera tetiana hoggar kovac est ce
que vous pensez justement d'une de ce
que vient de dire jean de gliniasty sur
une réflexion sur l'ensemble de la
sécurité en europe vous avez
l'impression que les ukrainiens y
gagnerait
bien sûr si l'insécurité un euro tout le
monde un bénéfice rei a aucun doute
c'est clair et net mais voulait
souligner en fait quand même que la
réponse que monsieur poutine à rochus
s'était pas la réponse uniquement des
états unis c'était bien la réponse des
l'otan c'est-à-dire que tous les pieds
un partenaire de l'otan membres de
l'otan levier y compris la france n'est
ce pas est donc d'aller d'année est la
réponse négative à l'exigence par
exemple de neutralité de certains pays
et l ukraine aujourd'hui ou bien quand
il exigé que le temps rockyou dans les
frontières d'eau 97 donc c'était non
après bien sûr il ya une réponse je suis
d'accord avec vous très techniques sur
dix missiles et autres choses ça c'est
une chose à discuter mais quand on nous
dit ici à l'ukraine que 1,7 une neutre
or autant peut sauver les situations au
peu calmé poutine jeu qui ont toujours à
vous rappeler qu'on était bien remplie
neutre et sans aucun statut a le temps
sans même espérance être membre de
l'union en 2014 au moment où on était un
peu inquiet par la russie la cuma et à
l'excès ou d'une basse était occupée et
c'est donc le statut neutre pour
l'ukraine veut dire un statut menacé à
chaque instant pas de file en direction
de l'ukraine 2 5 vrai dire cette fameuse
formule pas de faire lundi les actions
phares landivisiau pardon de l'ukraine
exactement exactement donc ne sais
qu'une autre veut dire pour nous le
danger qui sera toujours à nos côtés
puisqu'une et vous attend avec la russie
y sera ça sera toujours le cas alors le
seule solution pour nous ce sont les
garanties de sécurité que ce soit l'otan
que ce soit autre chose autre alliance
mais aujourd'hui il ya que entend en
fait pour être en sécurité relève aussi
parce que leur aide le vrai combat
aujourd'hui il est bien entre un régime
autoritaire la russie et autres régions
autoritaire de dents sont et les régimes
démocratiques et libres auxquelles le
cren veut participer et peut être membre
des états unis où la merci beaucoup
tetyana hoggar kova d'avoir été avec
nous merci à vous vous étiez en duplex
de berlin avec noir manzor remercie
beaucoup jean de gliniasty merci à vous
deux chefferies hawkins merci également
en roumanie ch donc à notre
correspondant merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis et reste avec nous sur
france 24
[Musique]